bonsoir la bataille qui avait cours
depuis quatre mois autour d'un projet
d'agrandissement d'un golf à oka au
nord-ouest de montréal a maintenant fait
un mort et ça fait trente ans jour pour
jour cette intervention de la sûreté du
québec à quel s attaquer cette opération
policière qui s'est soldée par la mort
du caporal lemay cette crise d'aucun
serge simon grand chef du conseil mohawk
de kanesatake était avec nous ce matin
bons jeunes s'estimant j'ai envie de
vous demander d'entrée de jeu où
étiez-vous il ya 30 ans comment
avez-vous personnellement vécu la crise
d'oka c'est a commencé ce matin là j'ai
vu les membres de la sûreté du québec en
bas de la côte d'ans fait d'avancé pour
une intervention et j'ai vu les soit
tactique un moment donné commencer à
monter la cote avec un camion j'ai monté
le moment donné un journaliste m'avait
approché le pouvoir si j'avais une façon
de monter l'eau et j'ai dit oui
suivez moi alors j'ai été accompagné par
un autre journaliste avec un mélomane de
la pinède et on s'est rendu au lieu de
l'abeille cas et c'est là qu'on a vu des
membres en train de courir dans ma
direction
entrée 2 essayer de se libérer les yeux
de lacrymogènes la sûreté du québec elle
élargit et sud à son écoute fut un peu
ici et là et le cp la fusillade complet
ce qu on allait juger tu es peut-être
une minute mais sa durée quoi secondes
et suite à sow j'ai témoigné aussi les
familles bulldozers qu'on avait apporté
vous démentez notre délicate ce fait
servi par napster
li membre de la communauté pour le
chemin est lié les barricades avec les
autos de sophie guilbert
or c'était un événement quand même
extraordinaire de ce nom n'étant pas
très vif en pour vous ce matin
oui absolument il ya eu plusieurs
instants sur l'a7 était là qu'on peut
démarquer à tout jamais dans notre dans
notre mémoire comme la fameuse à la
fameuse que je posais la can avant qui
va passer sur le pont avec les aînés de
gaouaoui qui avait été qui avait été
bombardée temps déjà sur le pont et puis
un mort sortie de cet événement ensuite
on a vu d'autres incidents ici
il choisit des violations de droit je
n'ai moi même j'étais money un design et
que la sûreté du québec avait ordonné de
dédougou sur le côté d'un tee shirt
l'ambroisie
ils faisaient comme quand quelques
degrés comme très chaud aujourd'hui
était planté sur sa canne et j'ai qui
lie après lui j'ai demandé gilles kleitz
au delà des sphères puis les hawks et
armés 10 5 e ils m'ont dit de rester ici
est il logique parle avec lui avec les
agendas soupe liquide a juste mentionné
qui est un aîné de la communauté il peut
pas rester au soleil comme solde et
suite à sausset c'est là que lyon ils y
ont laissé les n'est sortie du petit
chat ensuite vers la fin quand on boit
de la fin de la crise après 78 70 ça
aussi c'est des choses qui vont nous
laisser à tout jamais dans mémoire le
chef ghislain picard dit ce matin sur
notre site internet que les choses n'ont
pas vraiment changé depuis les 30
dernières années
et qu'il est temps de reconnaître le
racisme envers les premières nations est
ce que vous vous joignez à lui oui
absolument
ce régional bien raison on voit encore
dans le système judiciaire surtout dans
le système social de québec le racisme
là qu'on voit la hausse et c'est
toujours présents ont fait l'image de
fond qu'on peut mais ça va prendre du
temps ça va prendre aussi une éducation
il faut s'informer un peu ce qui on est
pourquoi on est comme on est vous allez
comprendre un petit peu la misère qui
nous avaient été imposées pour cela par
les prêtres mais avec l'adil x les
directives des gouvernantes depuis 200
ans
la misère qu'on avait souffert ici est
incroyable et 80 90 cette misère là a
explosé en rage pis la mentalité
colonialiste a encore qui existent même
avec l'uci le même le maroc aujourd'hui
que les mots rapport aucun droit ici que
l'état les partenaires auprès boillon
dont cette relation avec au cas elles ne
sont pas encore harmonieuse la somme en
scylla trois décennies plus tard je
continue à essayer de promouvoir la paix
oui compréhension on avait aussi
implémenter une table un comité de
liaison politique avec la merci de la
région justement pour le plus d'informer
les maires de la région que le maroc
sont ici que vous êtes à l'intérieur de
notre territoire
parce que j'ai informé la même année je
suis traité avec la grande bretagne
avaient été respectées ou qu'on n'aurait
dû jamais existé pointe-calumet
saint-joseph ni la belle ne le dit
jamais existé or aujourd'hui on voit que
la réalité
vous êtes là on est la personne dans son
beau disparaître le djihad admis alors
il faut accepter la réalité et sites web
à une station de police fait ensemble
paisiblement et équitablement
ouais donc beaucoup de travail à faire
encore en pour une réelle réconciliation
entre les peuples
et alors les cicatrices sont encore très
profondes on ressent un grand chef simon
merci beaucoup
nous avons parlé en cette journée
historique et en trente ans plus tard
après la crise d'oka merci beaucoup
mieux qu aulas on va